and roy dying on the sideline there
wilson
likes this shot that's why
lewis that shot he is exhausted at the
backboard too
look at that go somehow
that would be the way to go i think
[Applause]
oh he got it right off the top of the
window
dribble drive fine
to shoot what a scream by mccormick
martin
the little guy
big time kicker
got his 2 000 point and he's been unreal
since and he pointed at jim
with the layout
[Applause]
gotta keep manic off the glass
[Applause]
[Music]
they've got manic behind mccormick
misses the hook shot but got it back
wants it again wants it puts it up got
it high low action right now that's
their game right there mccormick he's
got to go up panic trying to keep him
away and he hits another one two
straight down the floor into the ball
harris i said
it was out of bounds
i think i don't know what happened
[Applause]
davis making an appeal
hopefully they might review it it's a
nice call nice set
oh yeah yeah that guy didn't go out of
bounds that left foot
twice
that worked wow
sure now you got a good shot they might
even have they might even add time here
that's a good point too on manic and
here we go manic circling around he
slipped underneath they go to love
love's gonna be the one to take it puts
up the shot it's off the game is over
and kansas completes the biggest
championship come back
all time
you